oh I'm worried here on the way from the
airport Hector from the Academy I was
driving me to the hotel and asked me
where's the origin of this the story of
your firmness then I told him yeah it
wasn't in a refugee camp in which an
explosion happened and and so we can
imagine a refugee camp and then a an
explosion happened in the refugee camp
and it wasn't that place and I and I
carried one of the two boys to the
hospital he asked me did it did it scar
you I looked at myself I thought no
actually it didn't scare me but then I
closed my eyes and I saw scars scars on
faces scars on houses scars on on hearts
and most of all scars on memories
permanent unhealable contagious it
passes to anyone new touch it passes
through generations and the saddest of
all it creates new violence new and more
scars but yet I believe that there is a
way to stop the scars from happening
there is a way to stop the scars from
happening once we stop being so confused
about who is right and I was wrong
and we put all this effort that we put
and all this energy to understand what
is right and what is wrong and we focus
on the people who are under this
argument the people who are daily in
daily basis the they are in this
conflict that we are arguing about this
at least will be a first step to stop
these scars from happening I want to
kiss all the hands that helped me to
make this film happen and I want to
switch my hand again because making the
film only does not tell the story you
know the effort is to to go with it and
tell the story so I would search my
empty hands again and I would appreciate
any help to to let me tell the story
again and again and again and I think
you are